what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
to be reacting to guy dum's girlfriend
for being too tall and lives to regret
his decision before i start do not
forget to subscribe to the channel and
ring that notification bell the way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos and as you guys know if you've
watched two or more of my videos and you
have not subscribed we have beef
beef all right okay
let's go also follow my instagram just
dot pearly things just dot pearly things
oh shoot we're gonna be late let's go
okay
seriously
you're really wearing heels gina yeah i
just bought these aren't they so cute no
that make you look like a giant he
dumped her i'm sorry respectfully she is
out of his league she's out of his
league respectfully respectfully too
tallest it is i don't need you looking
any taller
just take him off
but i i didn't bring any of the shoes to
her
this is gonna be so embarrassing
[Music]
embarrassing sir chill
guys you cannot change your height there
is no point
like there is no point in stressing over
how tall you are because you literally
cannot change it
i love being tall i would not
give that up for the world
i'm i'm 5 11. i'm almost six foot and i
swear to god if you're short just own it
there are girls that will still date you
even if you're short or even shorter
than them but if you're insecure about
it they will literally leave
hey matt it's good to see you man hey
you're my new girlfriend rosa
pleasure to meet you rosa wow
you're a lucky man
she's lovely
do you guys have any more uh wine
glasses
yeah i'll get them
so what's up man are you seeing anyone i
don't know oh um
no one special
sorry can one of you help me i can't
reach the wine glasses
sure
what the
they are really hard to reach
we might need a chair
i can help you
there you go he helps travel moms
thanks you must be a mets a friend
oh what the
the audacity sir she's so hot
my friend
nice to meet you
um cheers to uh matt's friend
[Music]
are you trying to do embarrass me
no i was only trying to help well don't
unless you like people thinking you're a
giant
gina the giant
what the [ __ ] there's a ring to it
doesn't it okay i don't this isn't real
i'm not even trying to say this but i
have never had an issue dating
due to my height to be honest like
for the most part guys have not cared
the most when i was in college i swear
to god five guys were the ones that
approached me the most the most
it's been a lot of hard work
explode
bombshell
[Applause]
gina you're nice okay let's do it all
right let's get gina
oh my god
giraffe
giraffe
crane
skyscraper
giants yes yes that's it
babe isn't that so funny we're just
talking about that
you really think this is all funny
they are laughing at you
not with you what the
bruh
bruh
wait
hey yeah what's going on i like tall
women okay this is what i found out with
this is my theory with dating okay
this is my theory with dating if a guy
is like
with tall guys i've noticed if a guy's
like
six two to six three like six one to six
three ish he prefers the five five girls
i i'm not his preference usually but if
i meet a guy that's like six four six
five and up
they like tend to like go for girls that
are like my height like five eleven
um that this is just what i found no
data just anecdotal evidence but
yeah i think it's a thing for like those
guys because i think the height
difference isn't as crazy
is is everything okay of course it's not
what the [ __ ]
did you see how the role is this
terrible acting lasting you for being a
giant
i'm sorry i i didn't take it like that
what if i took my heels off you still
look like a giant what the
look ces you can you could go get get
you get you a tall man you can't i
really tried to make this work gina i i
told myself
okay
she's a little tall
but so what
she treats you good
she cares a lot about you
but i'm sorry
i
i just can't tonight really confirmed it
all for me
what
all of this just because how tall i am
oh my god this is what men go through
daily i'm sorry guys this isn't fair to
you but this is what you go through
daily
well that's too bad then isn't it
you know
i'm such a good girlfriend to you
and all you care about is my height
one day you'll realize
it's not what's on the outside that
matters
it's what's on the inside
leave him what that he said not to me
take care
matt breaks up with gina and leaves her
there heartbroken
before long matt moves on and starts a
relationship with their new girl where's
she getting these baddies
[Music]
things seem to be going great
until he starts to notice that she
doesn't treat him as good as gina had
she wouldn't pay attention to him and
was always distracted
and she never even wanted to be seen in
public with him
she made him feel like he was worthless
the same way he made gina feel
matt quickly began to miss his
ex-girlfriend
they never appreciate us till we're gone
i'm not sad i'm not sad at all a couple
months go by and then one day he happens
to run into gina
hi reservation under the name gina sure
just give me a minute gina
wow i
i can't believe it's you oh
hey matt how how have you been
um
i've
i've been better actually
my uh
girlfriend i just broke up so
things have been kind of hard oh no i'm
so sorry that's okay
it was probably for the best
she didn't treat me the way
the way you did
you know i
thinking about you a lot lately
do you think we could maybe try again
excuse me
hey you mind taking a picture for me
please oh uh yeah yeah sure
i told you you could do better sis i
told you come here babe
[Applause]
oh
is she or he's he's way hotter he's way
hotter
she's my girlfriend
isn't she beautiful
yeah and he doesn't care and he doesn't
care
but
doesn't it bother you being with someone
you know
so much taller than you
are you kidding me
absolutely not look man for me it's not
what's on the outside that matters but
what's on the inside and look great
things come in tall packages
thank you so uh
do you all do know each other from
somewhere yes no no no that's like the
she's like don't do this don't tell my
friend
he was he was just my
friend your table's ready oh great
good to see you matt
bruh she's just borderline let's be
honest the average girl in the united
states is 150 pounds
i'm sorry
if you're in shape as a girl and you
have a nice face you're above average
you guys might not like it
it might not be a fun reality it's just
true
ellie stop barking
oh my gosh oh no
sorry
hey dar man fam make sure to subscribe
to my channel okay that was a fun video
that was a fun video
all right tallulah
oh wait no i think it's the feminine
truth that's her channel
feminine
truth
um
oh wait wait all right guys thank you
for watching the video um do not forget
to subscribe to the channel ring that
notification bell
that way you're going to be notified of
my daily videos and i will talk to you
guys next time
feminine truth sorry